close your eyes no really go ahead and
close your eyes please I want you to
think of your heart and while your
attention is on that beautiful four
chambered muscle I want you to think of
one thing that makes it beat wildly
without reason one thing that makes you
deliriously happy whatever it is I want
you to hold on to it right now
keep it close now look around your
families are supporting you from behind
you are sitting amongst some of the
truest friends you'll ever have and your
advisers and faculty lead you from up
here what has brought you to this point
our graduation day from a wonderfully
curious place CMU home of witty t-shirts
land parties and steam tunnels to my
portal fans out there where the cake is
a lie
we have Wien Hall whose transformation
to Optimus Prime is nearly complete you
can find our students cluster hoppin on
the weekends performing on Broadway or
building robots who go where no human
has ventured before we are surrounded by
people who care our staff our
administration and our professors some
so passionate about teaching that in
moments of academic reverie they smear
chalk all over their clothes because
they could care less about the erase
what a home we've had these past few
years and now it's time to go you may
not find such women's Akala tea or
passion in the real world in fact you'll
find a lot of bores and boxed thinkers
but that's not our thing My dear nerds
it's our turn to take CMU to the rest of
the world my heart is in the work how
many times have you heard it for
goodness sake my heart is in the work
good keep it there and take it
everywhere you go the world needs you
and your heart fundamentally it is the
center of love and if you think of some
of the happiest moments in your life or
at CMU who are they with so I'll be it
over said it's over said for a reason
stay in touch today make a promise to
yourself and your friends and say Bob if
we lose contact ten years from now fifty
years from now try and find me after all
we've got Facebook so call each other up
one evening and remember the halcyon and
hellish days that you spent together
fundamentally your heart harry's truth
french philosopher
pascal once said the heart has its
reasons which reason knows nothing of so
maybe you yearn to do something
remarkable to be someone special why not
what's holding you back
doubt fear failure it happens get over
it think of the things you want to
accomplish in your lifetime small big
don't be afraid of getting it wrong
that's silly you will
and then you try again and you get it
right take chances my friends because
nothing big or wonderful or beautiful or
epic ever came out of playing it safe
and following the rules be like Edison
who got it wrong
seven hundred times before he made it
work remember that every time you switch
on a light my dear friends trust that
your heart possesses brilliant instinct
ever heard of the paralysis of analysis
just do it do you want something ask for
it you'll be amazed at how people
respond leap and the net will appear
ever heard of the all-or-nothing law
when we're fact about the heart unlike
skeletal muscle the heart functions on a
physiological principle called the
all-or-nothing law and that is each time
it contracts it does so with all of its
force once it is set in motion it cannot
stop all or nothing let that propel you
and all that you do where will I end up
you may ask that I cannot say but I can
tell you where it begins right here
right here thank you
you